jedes Blackouts ist das eine gewisse Art
von Vorbereitung die man einfach Treffen
soll
frau kreidner von welchen Stromausfällen
welchen Ausmaßes sprechen sie denn wenn
sie von Strom Ausfällen reden sie
beraten ja auch Gemeinden und und und
Landkreise in Bayern im südlichen Bayern
was was verstehen sie unter Stromausfall
sie haben jetzt auch gesagt diese
Wahrscheinlichkeit haben sie das
österreichische Verteidigungsministerium
zitiert was meinen Sie oder was versteht
welches Ausmaß meinen sie
also wenn wenn ich Gemeinden oder oder
Kreise berate dann geht es bei uns
wirklich immer um das Worst Case
Szenario das dieses Worst Case Szenario
wenn man darauf vorbereitet ist dann ist
man automatisch für sehr viele andere
Krisen mit vorbereitet das heißt für
regionale Stromausfälle für rollierende
Stromabschaltungen oder automatischen
Lastabwurf oder sei es mal eine
Unterbrechung der Wasserversorgung der
Kommunikation oder Lieferketten
Unterbrechungen das heißt wenn man
darauf vorbereitet ist kann man sehr
viele andere Krisen sehr gut auch
abarbeiten oder abpuffern und deswegen
beschäftigen wir uns überwiegend eben
mit Blackout als ein Beispiel eines
Worst Case Szenarios um Gemeinden um
Landkreise Krisen fitter zu machen der
kleinere und wesentlich ungefährlichere
Bruder des Blackouts wurden
das ist im Unterschied das ist regional
begrenzt
im Prinzip ein Teil des Stromnetzes
vorübergehend abgeschaltet Stabilität zu
erhalten ob da immer eine Vorwahl
aber da reden wir dann wir haben ja so
eine Situation in Berlin gehabt Köpenick
ist halt großer Stadtteil der hat der
Bagger einen Kabel da waren auch wenn
ich es im Kopf habe 12 14 Stunden
überhaupt kein Strom und das ist auch
schon erheblicher Auswirkungen gehabt
und diese Diskussion die wir jetzt
führen ist ja immer die Angst der
Politik vor der Wahrheit
natürlich ist das sehr unwahrscheinlich
aber es kann es geben ich ich die
Situation in der Ukraine zeigt dass z.B
auch in einem Kriegsfall man vielleicht
versucht als erstes die Stromversorgung
kaputt zu machen ich sage nicht dass das
kommt die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist gering
und wir wollen das auch alle nicht aber
das zu kommunizieren und den Bürgern zu
sagen ist es gibt Situationen da wird
der Staat euch nicht sofort helfen
können und er müsst ihr euch irgendwie
selber helfen können im Alter z.B hat es
auch lange gedauert bis die Hilfskräfte
dort waren und ich glaube das ist die
Aufgabe von Politik auch von Städten und
Gemeinden es gibt nicht die einfache
Lösung wir können nicht so viel
Stromaggregate aufbauen dass das dann
weiter läuft aber wir müssen
zum Beispiel Wissen in einem Landkreis
und einer Stadt wie viel Menschen werden
zu Hause beatmet wir haben das mal
durchgespielt in einem Kreis glauben sie
mal nicht dass sie mal eben die Adressen
von den Leuten kriegen die Krankenhäuser
sagen wir dürfen das nicht sagen aus
Datenschutz können die
Pflegeeinrichtungen sagen Ihnen das
gleiche aber jeder weiß eine solche
Beatmung da ist ein Akku drin nach zwei
Stunden stirbt der Mensch also das sind
Kleinigkeiten und die Geld natürlich
auch beim Braun hat auch so dass es da
auch gesetzliche Regelung dafür gibt
also das heißt das ist ich habe
zumindestens jetzt in der Vorbereitung
gehört auch da muss im Regelfall eine
Vorwarnung sein wenn sie denn möglich
ist das regional begrenzt und auch
zeitlich begrenzt und ich glaube so
maximal im vier Stunden Tag von
Stadtteil zu Stadtteil das ist dann wäre
ja eigentlich auch einigermaßen noch
erträglich das ist das aber nicht wo vor
die Menschen eigentlich Angst haben das
ist in anderen Ländern übrigens auch
Gang und gelbe solche brown-outsierende
Last Abwürfe das haben wir in anderen
Ländern in Europa jedes Jahr das ist
durchaus Hände war trotzdem bei der
lenzberg recht aber wenn wir darüber
reden über Krisenvorsorge dann ist das
genau richtig was Sie ansprechen aber
das was sie gerade sagt haben wenn
Killer ist nämlich das Problem die Leute
haben nicht Angst vor schlechter
Krisenvorsorge die Leute werden gerade
politisch darauf eingestimmt Angst vor
einem Blackout zu haben also vor allem
Szenario vor dem man auch durchaus Angst
haben kann was einem Angst macht und
muss aber das wird ja hier gerade
politisch instrumentalisiert von allen
Seiten und da muss inklusive von der AFD
und das war sehr stark das muss man
immer wieder betonen und ich finde
deswegen ist das Wording ausschlaggebend
also wir müssen nicht von der Gefahr
eines Blackouts reden um die
krisenversorge zu stärken das ist nur
der Punkt den ich gerne machen möchte
gut wahrscheinlich ja und besser zu
Händel ist ein brown-out Frau Kreitner
als ein Stunden weißes Abschalten der
Infrastruktur wir haben es jetzt gerade
schon gesagt also regional begrenzt
zeitlich begrenzt es ist möglicherweise
kann man die Menschen auch noch Vorwand
was welche welchen Einfluss hat denn zum
ein solcher brown-out also wenn er nur
vier Stunden in Betrieben oder in
Privathaushalten herrscht und dann in
den nächsten Stadtteil wandert wer
welchen Einfluss hat er auf die
Funktionsfähigkeit der Infrastruktur
kann man dazu was sagen
auch also nicht nur den Betrieben
sondern auch eine Privathaushalten
ich denke das wird massiv unterschätzt
gerade im Bereich der kritischen
Infrastruktur und gerade auch im Bereich
der Produktion weil man rechnet ja damit
dass das dann nicht nur einen Tag lang
geht sondern dass das wirklich mehrere
Tage oder Wochen anhalten könnte und das
heißt zum Beispiel produzieren die
Betriebe die nicht darauf vorbereitet
sind in Deutschland weil wir eine sehr
hohe Versorgungssicherheit haben würden
dann die Produktionen herunterfahren und
erstmal abwarten bis die Stromversorgung
wieder gesichert ist also die fahren
nicht jeden Tag die Produktion hoch und
wieder runter das ist einfach nicht
realistisch und das gleiche ist auch im
Bereich der Pflege zum Beispiel
ambulante Pflegedienste sind nicht
darauf vorbereitet die analysezentren
sind auch sowas nicht vorbereitet und
auch pflegeheime sind nicht vorbereitet
dass ähm immer mal tagsweise
stundenweise dann der Strom weg ist wie
muss man sich denn das Vorstellen wir
reden jetzt also von diesem braun-out
also ein gesteuerter einigermaßen
kontrollierbarer Stromausfall über einen
längeren Zeitraum aber abwechselnd
Unterschied
Stromausfall Abschaltung Ausfall ist
schon wieder Kontrollverlust oben
Stromausfall zu vermeiden wir sagen
jetzt gar nicht mal wozu was da die
Ursachen sein könnten also gut
Stromabschaltung
Frau Kreitner da ist er immer die Frage
was fällt wie wann aus das will ja nicht
alles gleichzeitig also die Heizung wird
wahrscheinlich gleichzeitig aus die
Trinkwasserversorgung fällt nicht gleich
aus die Geldautomaten möglicherweise
funktionieren auch noch eine Zeit lang
Tankstellen werden irgendwann mal keine
Pumpen mehr haben also funktionierende
Pumpen das Tanken was fällt denn da wann
aus wie muss man sich das vorstellen ist
das dann so eine Kettenreaktion äh
nacheinander fallen die ganzen
Lebensgrundlagen weg
also bei den rollierenden
Stromabschaltungen ist es so dass
natürlich zuerst im Computer zum
Beispiel ausfallen zu Hause das Licht
geht aus kann man sich vorstellen
natürlich man kann auch nicht mehr
tanken dann wenn man in den zwei Stunden
oder vier Stunden gerade tanken möchte
ist das nicht möglich man kann kein Geld
abheben die Supermärkte die nicht
vorgesorgt haben die keine
Notstromversorgung haben da fallen die
Kassensysteme aus Handynetz hängt dann
davon ab wie groß die Gebiete sind die
abgeschalteten werden aber da kann es
auch dazu kommen dass auch die
handykommunikation dann ausfällt also es
hat schon auch Auswirkungen aber ich
möchte auch immer wieder betonenden
Stromausfall ist für die meisten von uns
auch nichts lebensgefährliches ja es ist
nichts was eigentlich ist bedrohlich
sein sollte ja also man kann das gut
händeln wenn man entsprechend auch ein
bisschen vorbereitet ist daheim und auch
entsprechend in den kritischen
Infrastrukturen man muss sich einfach
vorab Gedanken dazu machen und halt dann
Maßnahmen ergreifen also normal Blackout
Stromausfall brown- eigene
Stromabschaltung eine gezielte
Stromabschaltung die wird gibt es ja
meistens dann wenn die Stabilität des
Stromnetzes nicht mehr gewährleistet ist
sie muss ja immer 50 Herz haben wenn das
unterschritten wird dann muss zur
Stabilisierung des Netzes müssen muss
Strom abgeschaltet werden das ist der
eigentlich der der eigentliche Anlass
für diese Stromabschaltung woher kommt
denn diese diese unterbelastung des
Stromnetzes ja das kann verschiedene
Gründe haben gerade im kommenden Winter
Probleme geben wenn es zu kalt wird wenn
wir zu viel Sturm im Norden haben etc
also das das können vielfältige Gründe
sein warum es dazu kommt
letztendlich
ist hier glaube ich entscheiden dass und
das sagen uns zumindest die Experten für
den kommenden Winter das in den
allermeisten Fällen wenn der Winter
nicht zu kalt wird wir eine
halbwegs sichere Versorgung haben
sollten
ein Szenario das dass wir jetzt zum
Beispiel angeschnitten dass das
womöglich mehrere Wochen dauert selbst
das ist für den kommenden Winter da
müsst zum Beispiel sehr sehr kalt werden
über längere Zeit also das heißt Frauen
auch dieser sturmabschaltung müssen
verschiedene Komponenten zusammenkommen
da kann man ja schon vorschlagen also
wenn ein Kälteeinbruch droht wir haben
ja im Moment sondern inzwischen sehr
sichere Wettervorhersagen jedenfalls
kurzfristige oder wenn die Fragen Soßen
signalisieren es gibt zu wenig Strom aus
unseren AKWs dann es sind ja im Prinzip
die Kommunen die Landkreise die Städte
da schon drauf vorbereitet und können ja
entsprechende Vorkehrung treffen ja die
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber halten das ja
auch alles von oben sage ich mal im
Blick und die haben auch tägliche
Sitzungen wo die genau das schon eine
Woche im Voraus versuchen mit
Wetterprognosen mit nachfrageangebot
Prognosen festzustellen deswegen redet
man von Brauners natürlich können kann
das auch mal vorkommen vielleicht in
anderen Ländern dass sie ohne
Vorankündigung passieren aber in der
Regel gehen die
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber in Deutschland
davon aus dass sie das vorher sehen dass
sie das ankündigen können dass sie
maximal vier Stunden dauern und das dann
diese diese über- oder Unterlass die die
im Netz vorhergesehen wird auch übrigens
auf ganz Deutschland regional runter
tröpfelt verteilt wird also es wird dann
in sehr sehr kleinen Kaskaden nur
Auswirkungen haben das heißt vielleicht
ist es in Berlin
einen Teil von Friedrichshain oder ein
Teil von irgendeinem anderen Stadtteil
und dann rolliert das so war das gemeint
und selbst das Halten eben aufgrund der
milden Wetterprognosen die Experten
mittlerweile für gar nicht mehr so
wahrscheinlich weil haben wir einen
milden Winter erwarten aber ja wenn sich
das ändert wir können ja auch viel dafür
tun als Einzelpersonen um das in Grenzen
zu halten die Probleme die Heizlüfter
sind ja wie warm ist Semmel über die
Baumarkt und Einrichtungshäuser tegen
gegangen das sieht ja wahre Stromfresser
die eigentlich der Stromausfälle
vielleicht nicht aber die Notwendigkeit
einer Stromabschaltung erst
wahrscheinlich machen ja das ist ein
bisschen ironisch leider also im
Baumarkt werden sie gerade immer noch
überall angepriesen gehen auch immer
noch wie war eine Semmel über die Theke
Gott sei Dank haben wir den Zustand dass
sie Gasspeicher 100% voll sind die Leute
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so panisch
sind dass sie dass sie in die Gasheizung
ausgeht aber ich möchte gerne mal
betonen dass Gas immer noch
günstiger ist auf die Kilowattstunde
gesehen als Strom im Moment also diese
Heizlüfter sind auch und das haben viele
Menschen im Alter glaube ich auch
erfahren
wahnsinnig Strom fressen also wer die
anmacht um Geld zu sparen der wird sein
blaues Wunder erleben nächstes Jahr das
ist leider nicht
zielführend aber es sind 800.000
verkauft worden wenn die alle
gleichzeitig laufen dann haben wir ein
echtes Problem gut ich meine die haben
ja vielleicht auch zu Hause schon welche
gehabt das ist nicht ganz Deutschland
gleichzeitig ganz Deutschland
gleichzeitig kalt aber wenn das eine
größere Fläche ist mit mehreren
Großstädten dann kann das schon Probleme
geben gerade gesagt so in den Nebensatz
was die Frau Kreitner ja zum Thema noch
äh zum zum Heizlüftern wobei diese genau
die Heizlüfter wurden auch in den Stress
dass der Übertragungsnetzbetreiber mit
einberechnet schon ja also da muss man
wirklich keine Angst haben dass das dann
dazu führt dass es Netz lahm liegt nur
weil die Heizlüfter ans Netz gehen also
das wurde von den Übertragungsnetz wird
Betreibern bereits mit einem berechnet
die haben das auf dem Schirm
empfunden
die Leute sollen sich oder dürfen sich
immer nur auf die Gemeinden auf die
Kommunen verlassen die müssen auch
selbst etwas tun aber das ist ja genau
die Erwartungshaltung wenn ein ob jetzt
eine Abschaltung oder im schlimmsten
Fall der Stromausfall passiert dass
tatsächlich die Kommunen dann eine
Notfallplan haben mit dem sie die
Bevölkerung unterstützen wenn das nur
kurzfristige Ausfälle sind der
Kühlschrank geht dabei nicht kaputt ist
genügend Wasser und Konservendosen zu
Hause dann spielt das keine Rolle aber
bei den längeren Zeitraum sehr wohl kann
man sich nicht auf seine Kommune
verlassen sondern Situationen natürlich
kann man sie auf seine Kommune verlassen
das ist ja auch so dass die Kommunen
insgesamt das werden Sie sicherlich
bestätigen können sich schon auf den Weg
machen mit krisenstäben auch die Länder
machen sehr viel ich weiß dass das
Nordrhein-Westfalen da werden Tanklager
geschaffen für Polizei und Feuerwehr es
werden Vorräte angelegt aber das ist ein
Prozent der würde ich sagen realistisch
in den letzten vier fünf Monaten läuft
und es gibt eben letztlich kein
überregionales Krisenmanagement gesehen
also wenn eine Schadenslage Eintritt die
eine Ländergrenze in Deutschland
überschreitet da haben sie ein riesen
Problem und wenn es eine ist die mehrere
Länder oder dann haben sie das nächste
unintelligible Problem deswegen sage ich
wir brauchen eigentlich auf der
Bundesebene eine nationalen Krisenstab
und auf der Länderebene eingegebenen
falls auch
länderübergreifenden Krisenstab damit
wir wir so schön heißt vor die Lage
kommen brauchen wir denn in den
Gemeinden Kreisen doch natürlich das
haben wir ja auch nur wenn die Gemeinde
im Aatal nicht weiß dass
110 km weiter der Fluss sich staut weil
der Nordrhein-Westfalen ist dann nützt
den das nicht das ist eine
informationsfrage es ändert aber nichts
an der Tatsache dass wir den Leuten
einfach auch mehr Vorsorge ich sag das
jetzt mal ein bisschen erzieherisch
beibringen müssen es gibt seit Jahren
diese Liste des BBK was sollte man haben
also für 14 Tage Wasser eine
Taschenlampe die mit Batterie läuft
vielleicht ein Akku Kerzen ein bisschen
was zu essen früher hat das keinen
Menschen interessiert das auch
interessant ein Ergebnis dieser
Diskussion das können sich runterladen
und Sie können es als Broschüre im BBK
bestellen Moment ist die Broschüre
vergriffen also das ist
so ein Gefühl also
fragen wir haben jetzt den wahren Tag am
8 Dezember machen sie meine Umfrage auf
der Straße wer weiß eigentlich welcher
Signalton bedeutet was
das wissen die Leute nicht und das hat
sich auch im Alter gezeigt die Leute
sind in den Keller gegangen bei
Hochwasser und sind gestorbenweise im
Keller noch was regeln wollten wir sind
wir haben das nie eingeübt und das muss
besser werden weil auch immer alles zur
Verfügung stellen und wenn man alles
funktioniert
Supermarkt gegangen jetzt haben weil sie
gesagt haben da gibt es auch auf
kommunaler Ebene entsprechende Vorsorge
unsere Kollegen von Report Mainz vom
Südwest Rundfunk ja eine Umfrage gemacht
unter den deutschen Landkreisen und
Kommunen also auch in ihrem
Landsberg da haben etwa die Hälfte der
Gemeinden und und Städte geantwortet
dass etwa die Hälfte nämlich 101 dieser
Gemeinden und Landkreise keinen
funktionsfähigen Notfallplan haben nach
denen Auskunft 78 haben keine notbrunnen
obwohl der glaube ich gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben ist für die Not
Trinkwasserversorgung und 67 keine
Anlaufstelle in der Gemeinde wo man sich
hinwenden kann was soll ich jetzt tun
was passiert können Sie mich informieren
das sind ja eigentlich relativ
nüchternde zahlen das sind ganz
ernüchterne zahlen wobei das hat
natürlich eine große Welle ausgelöst in
der kommunalen Familie der ist gesagt
weil die haben die Frage falsch gestellt
ich sage das nur der ist nämlich
angeblich teilweise gefragt worden haben
sie einen Krisenstab bei denen heißt der
aber nicht Krisenstab sondern der heißt
bei den notfallstab also haben gesagt
haben wir nicht mal drauf kommen können
dass das gemeint ist ist gar kein
Vorbild also da gibt es Defizite die
Defizite müssen wir lösen die müssen
auch die Kommunen lösen das schaffen sie
aus meiner Sicht nicht alleine wir
brauchen da einen Bündnis für den
zivilen Katastrophenschutz von
bundländern und Kommunen wir müssen auch
mal drüber reden welche Rolle spielt
eigentlich die Bundesliga wir haben ja
diese klare Trennung zwischen äußeren
und inneren Angelegenheiten aus
verfassungsrechtlichen Gründen
funktioniert das denn eigentlich in der
corona-krise hat das nicht funktioniert
19000 Soldaten haben über 20 Millionen
Arbeitsstunden leisten müssen weil der
zivile Schutz versagt hat und im Alter
darf ich mal daran erinnern die
Feuerwehr hatte kein einziges
wattfähiges Fahrzeug das ist jetzt kein
Vorwurf an Rheinland-Pfalz ist ein
anderen Ländern genauso oder denken Sie
an die Waldbrände wer fliegt denn da und
löscht das ist entweder die Bundeswehr
ab und zu mal die Polizei der zivile
Katastrophenschutz hat das nicht und das
müssen wir insgesamt anders angehen das
ist mindestens genauso wichtig wie der
tüchtigung der Bundeswehr er ist auch
eine Frage der das Bewusstseins der
Menschen ist jetzt hier so angeklungen
jahrzehntelang haben wir die sogenannte
Friedensdividende genossen ähm da kann
nichts passieren wir sind alles Elend
alle Katastrophen dieser Welt sind weit
weg manchmal passiert es auch bei uns
hier Aathal aber ist kein Vergleich mit
seinen Zone oder den Inselstaaten im
Pazifik wir leben da hier auf einer
Insel der Seligen dieses Bewusstsein uns
kannst ja nichts passieren oder das auch
nie gelernt zu haben das ist
Katastrophen das ist Aufnahme
Situationen geben kann ist das eines der
größten Hemmnisse bei der Bewilligung
dieser Frage jetzt sicher ich bin ja zum
Beispiel noch aus einer Generation die
zu den den das Ende Kalten Krieges noch
mitbekommen hat damals hat man da ein
ganz anderes Bewusstsein gehabt noch
diesbezüglich mit 89 würde ich sagen hat
das so begonnen zu verschwinden
und was ich ganz interessant fand in dem
Kontext seit Erscheinen des Buches
beispielsweise vor zehn Jahren war ich
wirklich bei hunderten Veranstaltungen
verschiedenster Art von Bürgermeister
bis zur eu-kommissan Unternehmen
Behörden etc dass das Bewusstsein über
die Jahre ja gewachsen ist aber leider
Bewusstsein alleine reicht noch nicht
wegen dem dann keine Handlungen folgen
also das muss scheinbar immer etwas
passieren damit was passiert und mir
kommt vor dass da jetzt natürlich die
Pandemie schon mal sehr viel geholfen
hat wenn wir von Vorbereitung zum
Beispiel sprechen ich erinnere nur an
die Tage nach dem Beginn des ersten
lockdowns ich sage nur Nudeln und
Klopapier ne da merkt man dann plötzlich
ach ja gar nicht doof wenn man was zu
Hause gehabt hätte für ein paar Tage
einen hätte man nicht panisch die
klopapiere alle es muss ja nicht immer
der Blackout sein so ein
Grundvoraussetzung unserer Gesellschaft
du musst ein paar Tage krank werden
meinetwegen oder eingeschneit werden
obwohl das mit dem Ziel mit der
Klimakrise immer selten und wird aber
ja
natürlich den Klimakrise
werden die die Bargeldautomaten
aufmunitionieren das ist ja glaube ich
im Sommer in Berlin passiert dass wir
sofort auf gleich unangenehm auf das
weiß noch relativ harmlos mit dem was
uns da blühen könnte Frau Kreitner jetzt
werden ja Politikerinnen und Politiker
auch auf der kommunal Ebene gewählt
Verantwortung zu übernehmen
vorausschauend zu halten Schaden von der
Bevölkerung zu nehmen sie sind Beraterin
bei diesen Kommunen und Landkreisen in
Südbayern ist da das Bewusstsein auf der
politischen Ebene oder wie man so schön
sagt in der politischen Klasse schon so
weit geblieben dass jetzt inzwischen die
Gefahr erkannt haben dass man
zumindestens vorbereitet sein muss auch
wenn dann hoffentlich nichts passiert
also das ist nicht nur in der Politik
der Fall ich sehe das seit einem halben
Jahr dass auf allen Ebenen eigentlich
das Risiko Bewusstsein geweckt wird das
doch Dinge passieren können die man nie
erwartet hätte und tatsächlich wenn
dieses Risiko Bewusstsein mal da ist und
man ein bisschen unterstützt dann gehen
die Leute und auch die Politiker und
auch die kritischen Infrastrukturen
tatsächlich in die Umsetzung also ich
sehe das hier in Oberbayern und Schwaben
das ist von der Kreisebene
runtergebrochen auf
Blaulichtorganisationen auf die
Gemeinden Ebenen dass tatsächlich sehr
viele auch die Konzepte umsetzen um
insgesamt Krisen fitter zu werden ja
also ich glaube vielen ist klar diese
krisenfreien Zeiten die wir hatten das
muss nicht auch immer so weitergehen ja
und ähm viele merken jetzt auch okay bei
überregionalen Katastrophen kommt
erstmal keine Hilfe von außen das heißt
man ist auf sich gestellt und dann wäre
es schon klug vorzusorgen also ich war
heute zum Beispiel bei einer Gemeinde
und die Bürgermeisterin hat zu mir
gesagt ja wissen Sie wir alle dass ja
nichts passiert aber ich bin ein Mensch
ich bin lieber vorbereitet dass wenn der
Fall eintritt wir das gut handhaben
können als das eine Situation kommt und
wir gar keine Vorbereitung haben keine
Anlaufstellen für die Bevölkerung keine
Ahnung wie wir Krisenstab bilden sollen
also lieber vorsorgen denn egal was dann
kommt dann sind wir vorbereitet also
wenn das jetzt der Bürgermeister oder
was wieder gesagt hat und das war
kneipner da erlebt hat das ist ja
entweder die Vogel strauß-politik den
Kopf ins Land zu stecken wird schon
nichts passieren oder das sogenannte ST
Florians Prinzip heiliger ST Florian
verschoben mein Haus sind andere an aber
diese Einstellung
ist die doch
verbreitet auch aus ihrer Praxis
vielleicht heraus zu sagen dass man sagt
na ja also das wird bei uns schon nicht
passiert also es gibt beides das
Bewusstsein ist gestiegen das hat er die
Umfrage auch ergeben es wird sicherlich
da auch über den Gesetzgeber auf Bundes-
und Landesebene noch mal Vorgaben geben
aber muss auch mal ehrlich sein wenn sie
im Wahlkampf stehen und stehen vor der
alternative ich mache mir für
Katastrophenschutz oder neuen
Kindergarten wir wird in der Wähler wohl
entscheiden im Moment ist das ein Thema
und da sagen ja auch 53 Prozent da muss
was geschehen ich will geschützt werden
reden wir noch mal in drei Monaten
können Sie ein schönes Beispiel nehmen
nach der Flutkatastrophe im Aartal sind
diese
universalschadensversicherung durch die
Decke gegangen die Leute wollten alle
versichert sein gegen alles und wie ist
es jetzt genauso wie vorher also das
Gedächtnis ist da auch kurz insofern bin
ich nicht so sicher ob es anhält aber es
ist eine Aufgabe der Politik dafür zu
sorgen klar aber wenn es so schwierig es
wird immer erst eine Schmerzgrenze
überschritten sein muss bevor etwas
wirklich passiert und es ist Bewusstsein
rückt vielleicht auch irreversibel ins
bewusstseindrückt ist das ja auch
schwierig welche Möglichkeiten hat die
Politik da eigentlich noch außer
sozusagen wir sind im Wahlkampf und der
Kindergarten ist für viele auch wichtig
ne also ich glaube dass wir brauchen
Kommunikationskonzepte keine Panik
machen das haben sie völlig richtig
gesagt aber zu sagen wir tun alles damit
Ihr in solchen Situation Boden geschützt
seid ihr müsst wissen wenn der Strom
ausfällt und sind es noch fünf Stunden
wie melde ich denn die Oma hat ein
Herzinfarkt gekriegt wo gehe ich denn
hin das ist ja jetzt keine große
finanzielle Aufwand es gibt größere
Dinge da wird es komplizierter und auch
das was das BBK ja aus meiner Sicht
wirklich toll macht nur es ist nicht in
den Hinterköpfen der Menschen es müsste
auch mal im Kino laufen kommunikation
ist alles aber auch in dem Bereich ist
Kommunikation ganz wesentlich und da
müsste mehr geschehen und da sollte
Politik auch mal den Mut haben es hat
zum Beispiel vor einigen Jahren man
Diskussion gegeben ob man nicht mal eine
große Übung macht eine große Übung [ __ ]
tief ein Flugzeug stürzt über Frankreich
ab jetzt muss gar nicht Terror sein soll
sie haben weil es in der Mitte der Stadt
abstürzt sechs oder zehntausend
verletzte wie organisiere ich das dass
die versorgt werden dass die Abtransport
wir wer hat den Hut auf welche Rolle
spielt die Bundeswehr die Polizei und
ähnlich ist das ist dann nicht gemacht
worden wie ich weiß wenn man sagt wir
wollen die Bevölkerung nicht beunruhigen
und das ist auch wichtig wir müssen die
Dinge üben und zwar nicht nur abstrakt
sondern auch hin und wieder mit bevölker
also die Leute nicht beunruhigen ist das
eine Panikmache das Stichwort viel auch
schon wie sieht es denn damit aus also
das ist schwierig das die kommunikative
Frage wurde ja gerade am Anfang schon
angeschnitten man hat das Feld hier
leider
den rechten überlassen zur Panikmache
tut dann meiner Meinung nach zum Teil
ein überkompensieren in die andere
Richtung überhaupt keine Gefahr was was
auch wiederum ein Problem ist aber es
ist ja generell in unserer Diskurs
Kultur heutzutage wahnsinnig schwierig
noch einen vernünftige Diskussion zu
finden also ich möchte auch nicht der
Politiker sein der auch vernünftige Art
und Weise momentan da draußen die
Bevölkerung informiert ähm es wird
jedesmal irgendeine Agenda dahinter
vermutet wenn ein Unternehmen sagt bitte
Bereich bezeichnet heißt sicher die
wollen nur Geld damit verdienen ähm egal
welcher Politiker sagt wird man
irgendeine Agentin also ich muss
gestehen dass das ist momentan sehr sehr
schwierig zu kommen manche
Diskussionsbeiträge in Social Media
Kanälen auch nicht unbedingt hilfreich
ähm Stichwort ist noch bei der Abteilung
Panik mache Rolle der Medien was ist wie
ist das da in diesem ganzen Kontext
einzuschätzen ja ich finde das
tatsächlich viele Medien dieser
Panikmacher auch an Heim fallen gerade
muss ich sagen also ich
es kommt halt immer darauf an wie man
Fragen stellt also wenn man jetzt was
dazu schreibt oder ein Beitrag
formuliert wie wahrscheinlich ist ein
Blackout kann man das machen wenn man
darüber auch die Informationen raus gibt
die ja in Landsberg zum Beispiel meinen
also wie bereite ich mich denn vor wie
kann ich dann trotzdem Notruf absetzen
also dass man das alles ins richtige
Licht drückt aber nicht sagt na ja wenn
hier im Blackout kommt dann aber gute
Nacht liebe Freunde und dann ist ganz
Deutschland
geht vor die Hunde das ist natürlich
überhaupt nicht hilfreich und ich glaube
was die Politik schon gemacht hat und
was ein guter und wichtiger Schritt ist
gerade mit Blick auf das was im Alter
passiert ist ist das am 8 Dezember ja
auch zum ersten Mal diese Warnungen aufs
Handy gespielt werden ne das ist das ist
ein unheimlich großer Schritt den es
glaube ich ohne dass sie nicht gegeben
hätte und ähm dass da sowas ist sehr
sehr wichtig und mit so einem warmen Tag
und mit dem dass die Leute auch damit
konfrontiert werden auf Ihrem Smartphone
und ich glaube
kann schon was bringen ich weiß nicht
wie hilfreich das ist dass das BWK
Kochbücher fürs Kochen ohne Strom witzig
darstellt im Internet die also die die
meinen das sicher gut die machen auch
viele gute Sachen aber gerade hier
Stichwort was kann man machen auch mit
den Medien wäre ein
Präsident des BBK der richtig die
richtige Balance hat bei diesem Thema zu
kommunizieren glaube ich sehr sehr
wichtig und hilfreich es ist die
Abkürzung BBK mehrfach genanntlich
zwischendurch wissen noch mal in voller
Form sagen Bundesamt für
Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe
welche Rolle kommenden Medien dazu wird
wenn Sie diese Rolle gerecht im
Positiven wie ein negativ waren
Instrument als Unterstützer der der
Politik und der Verwaltung auf der
anderen Seite die Leute Tiere zu machen
ich ich würde jetzt die Medien nicht zu
übernehmen kann Scheren es gibt Medien
die seriöser berichten und andere die
das halt ähm zum click beten
letztendlich verwenden ist einfach
Aufmerksamkeit zu erregen nehmen wir das
Beispiel dieser Aussage von vor ein paar
Tagen wo der Chef des BBK gesagt hat wir
müssen uns im Winter womöglich auf
Blackout vor zu vorbereiten und dann
nachgeschoben hat im selben Interview
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe mit
Blackout meine ich gezielte regionale
Abschaltung also eigentlich hat er nicht
vom Blackout gesprochen
wahnsinnig ungeschickt formuliert wenn
ich aber als Medium jetzt her gehe und
sag was meinen Sie jetzt eigentlich
meinen sie Blackout oder Abschaltung wie
sollen wir denn das jetzt kommunizieren
könnte ich machen oder ich gehe einfach
hin und sagt Blackout gesagt
warnt vor Blackouts im Winter war glaube
ich die Überschriften genau das ist der
Punkt
da kann ich als Medium jetzt sagen okay
sie haben ja eigentlich Abschaltungen
gemeint dann schreibe ich Abschaltung in
der Umgang aber das interessiert
natürlich
muss man auch sagen es war sehr sehr
unglücklich bis unprofessionell das so
zu kommentieren aber ich muss jetzt dann
nicht immer unbedingt auch noch als Bahn
verstärken in der Öffentlichkeit auch
kaum bekannt ist dass dieses besagte BBK
außer im Kriegsfall ja gar keine
Befugnis hat das ist eine reine
Beratungsfunktion ich halte das für
falsch ich glaube dass dem bestimmten
Katastrophenlagen auch eine
Weisungsbefugnis haben sollten ich weiß
dass die Länder dann sagen hier wir sind
auch zuständig die Kommunen auch aber
darüber muss auch gesprochen werden aber
das ist eine Frage des Gesetzgebers gut
das damit ähm kratzen wir am Prinzip das
Föderalismus eigene Sendung
ist das aus ihrer Praxis auch so jetzt
die Leute also sie kommen ja mit vielen
Menschen zusammen dass da Angst
vorherrscht oder ist das eher so eine
Art Vorsicht oder dass man irgendwie
nicht genau weiß oder jetzt wirklich
Angst zu haben schon gar keine Panik
welche wie reagieren die Leute gerade
jetzt in der Frage war jetzt ein
kältereinbruch kriegen wir noch genügend
Gas kriegen wir noch genügend Strom
also die Leute also ich habe bisher noch
niemanden gesehen der jetzt hier
irgendwie in Panik ausgebrochen ist ja
ähm wir hatten hier jetzt in Bayern auch
viele Sensibilisierungen was bedeutet
dass die Behörden Gemeinden und auch
Kreise die Bevölkerung darauf
hingewiesen haben dass da ein Risiko ist
ja und das ist Sinn macht Notfall
Vorräte anzulegen was wir gesehen haben
ist das sehr viele Leute das dann
tatsächlich machen also die Supermärkte
sind relativ leer es heißt aber nicht
dass das deswegen panikäufe sind sondern
die Leute gehen dann mit den Checklisten
einkaufen und gehen damit auch
vernünftig um also da heißt es dann im
Ort ja der netto ist heute leer wegen
der Aktion gehst halt morgen wieder
einkaufen also die kriegen das wirklich
sehr gut auch hin selbst wenn da
Informationen stattfinden das ist das
eine und auch bei den Vorträgen oder
auch auf kreisebenen und auf
gemeindeebenen habe ich bisher nie
jemanden gehabt der hat dann irgendwie
ganz panisch wurde also ich
es ist verständlich wenn man sich mit
Worst Case Szenarien befasst dass man
erstmal ein ungutes Gefühl hat aber die
Sache ist die man hat es ja in der Hand
man kann ja vorsorgen und das ist ja das
Gute daran und mit jedem Schritt den man
mehr vorsorgt ist man auch beruhigt da
ja also ich meine ich setze mich ja auch
ins Auto und schneide mich an weil ich
dann beruhigter bin sollte ein Unfall
passieren ja und das gleiche ist es auch
mit der Krisenvorsorge da möchte
schreiben kriege weil ich da in der
Diskussion drin dass die Leute mir
schreiben ja ich ich bin Mieter ich habe
eine ganz kleine Wohnung ich habe keinen
Keller wo soll ich denn für zwei Wochen
wasserstapeln andere sagen ich habe gar
kein Geld diese Vorräte zu schaffen das
ist auch nicht so ganz ohne wir leben ja
nicht alle in dem Einfamilienhaus in
Bayern oder in einer schönen Wohnung wo
Platz ist auch da muss man nachdenken in
solchen Krisensituationen das heißt es
wird wahrscheinlich auch
regional Depots geben müssen wo man
bestimmte Dinge die dann vielleicht auch
haltbar ist vorher halten aber ich
möchte dass also jeder hat auch eine
Eigenverantwortung zur Vorsorge und ich
ähm glaube nicht dass man die ganze
Verantwort an die Politik oder Kommunen
abgeben kann dass das nicht funktioniert
haben wir im Ahrtal gesehen da waren die
Leute mehrere Tage auf sich gestellt
hatten hätten sich gewünscht sie hätten
all diese Vorräte zu Hause gehabt an der
Stelle aber ich glaube es ist so ein
bisschen fifty-fifty also man muss auch
an die Leute selbst appellieren damit
Umsicht mit Vorsicht sich vorzubereiten
und man kann nicht alles abwälzen glaube
ich das muss man ganz klar betonen
ein Gesichtspunkt würde ich gerne noch
mal bringen wir müssen natürlich noch
vielleicht darf ich noch ganz kurz was
dazu sagen zu den kleinen Wohnungen und
zum kleinen Budget es ist zum einen
nicht so dass man gleich den
krisenvorrat komplett einkaufen gehen
muss also wir empfehlen das auch Schritt
für Schritt wir haben eine Infokampagne
Schritt für schritt-fit das heißt bei
jedem Einkauf nimmt man ein bisschen was
von der Liste mit ja die Supermärkte
sind auch man kann wirklich jetzt sich
über die Zeit langsam auch in
krisenvorrat zulegen das ist das eine
zum zum kleinen Geldbeutel und das
zweite ist auch bei kleinen Wohnungen
wenn man wirklich möchte ja dann findet
man Platz man findet vielleicht unterm
Bett kann man vielleicht ein bisschen
Wasserflaschen reinmachen oder neben die
Jeans hat noch haben noch nudelpackungen
Platz und ein bisschen Krisen fordert
ist immer noch besser als gar keiner da
macht man halt nur für 10 Tage ja das
ist besser als nichts also man muss da
ein bisschen kreativ auch sein und nicht
stark nach nach Liste ich muss jetzt ähm
für meine vier Personen 20 Kilo
Getreideprodukte 18 Kilo Gemüse und
Hülsenfrüchte und so weiter auf einmal
einkaufen also das denke ich
kann man auch einfach Schritt für
Schritt machen und man sollte einfach
das Einkaufen was man so auch gerne ist
und dementsprechend dann einfach wieder
rollieren verbrauchen und nachkaufen
jetzt haben wir ja von eher Milten
Auswirkungen eines komfortverzichts
durch weniger Strom oder zeitweise kein
Strom gesprochen es gibt die gebe ja
noch andere Ursachen als das jetzt
aufgrund der nicht vorhandenen
Netzspannung Strom ausfällt dann
Stichwort Terra Akte
Sprengstoffanschläge selber Attacken ist
das dann dann sind sie aber in diesem in
diesem Bereich das ist ein kommenden
große Schwierigkeiten das um vielleicht
die Szenarien noch ganz kurz mal zu
differenzieren wir haben über das Braun
hat gesprochen
regional kurz Stromausfall auch eher
regional auch nicht zu lang aber halt
ein bisschen Kontrollverlust das nächste
wäre ein normaler Blick hat weil nicht
absichtlicherweise geführt da wären
ihnen die Energie Experten rundherum
sagen selbst wenn es dazu kommt hat man
sowas binnen Stunden bis maximal im
schlimmsten Fall für manche Gebiete drei
vier Tage war seine Katastrophe ist für
die Gebiete unter Kontrolle
was anderes ist wenn wenn jemand bewusst
versucht die Netze unten zu halten das
ist das Szenario meines Buches das ist
im weiteren Krieg mit gewissen Mitteln
unter anderem das Blackouts wir sehen
das jetzt in der Ukraine dann sind wir
in einer ganz anderen Situation da
helfen dir auch die Vorbereitung für die
nächsten 10 14 Tage nur sehr bedingt
muss man auch klarerweise
Differenzierung dass das ja höchst
unterschiedliche Ursachen auch haben
kann jetzt ist es ja so
Stromausfall stromabstandung ist schon
unangenehm wenn man den Strompreis nicht
bezahlen kann auch das geht jetzt ein
bisschen weg von dem Thema vielleicht
zum Schluss der Sendung strompreisbremse
das scheint eine höchst komplizierte
Angelegenheit zu werden möglicherweise
hilft sie gar nicht so sehr
den Eindruck würde ich jetzt nicht so
unterstreichen Wirkung kommt entweder
gar nicht oder zu spät es ist auch sehr
komplex gemacht wird vielleicht eher mit
Einmalzahlungen laufen sollen
es ist es ist sehr komplex aber mit
Einmalzahlungen hätte man die
Strompreise sind über einen längeren
Zeitraum werden die auf diesem hohen
Niveau bleiben ich glaube Einmalzahlung
hätten nicht gereicht und ja es ist
komplex aber so wie es jetzt aufgebaut
ist ist mit Blick auf die Zeit die beste
Alternative sie hätte in meinen Augen
früher kommen müssen definitiv jetzt
müssen die Leute erstmal gucken wie sie
bis März beim Strom zumindest über die
Runden kommen dann geht es ja
rückwirkend ab Januar aber ich glaube
wichtig ist dass der dass der sparenreiz
erhalten bleibt eben gar nichts
ich finde das nicht unbedingt Computer
als beim Gas ist eigentlich
verabschiedet worden ist von der Politik
die strompreisbremse
also eigentlich heute kam ja der
Gesetzentwurf wo beides Finale die
Eckpunkte kamen wo beides final wurde
länger gedauert als strompreisbremse
vielleicht weil die die Erlös
Abschöpfung damit dran hängt aber
eigentlich vom Prinzip her geht läuft
beides gleich ab beim Strom fällt
entfällt nur die Einmalzahlung im
Dezember aber ansonsten ist sich das
relativ ähnlich bis auf die Uhr getragen
natürlich und die Gaspreise sind
natürlich viel schneller explodiert ne
die Strompreise steigen aber niemals so
drastisch wie die Gaspreise und ich
finde schon man kann natürlich da würde
ich Ihnen auch recht geben die Politiker
dem April sich schon auf dem Weg machen
müssen aber es ist schon hoffnungssignal
und dass das ganz komplizierte Vorgänger
ist das muss man verstehen ich glaube
viele Menschen empfinden das als
Hoffnung und das ist auch schon was in
diesem Krisenzeiten gut das damit sind
wir am Ende dieser Sendung ganz bestimmt
nicht mit diesem Thema Mark Elsberg
bedanke mich
Alexandra Kreitner bei Katrin Beach und
bei Gerd Landsberg Liebe ZuschauerInnen
liebe Zuschauer morgen in der Phönix
Runde Kompromiss beim Bürgergeld wer hat
sich durchgesetzt wahrscheinlich wird
morgen live in der Phönix Runde auch das
Ergebnis bekannt gegeben werden und am
spätestens am Freitag dann von Bundesrat
und Bundestag verabschiedet sein damit
das Bürgergeld zum ersten Januar in
Kraft treten kann
aktuell ist ein weiteres bei Felix der
Tag mit Maja Weber auch darin geht es um
das Bürgergeld denn damit das morgen
einigermaßen schnell durchgehen kann
sind noch jede Menge
Vorgespräche und Sondierungen
erforderlich bleiben Sie bei uns